sunday surprise time
week nine already week nine and look
let me just pause for a second here and
congratulate the nfl on getting through
nine sundays with every game that was
supposed to be played played yes
some games had to be shifted yes one
game had to move from one week two three
weeks later and one moved from uh sunday
to the next sunday and we had a tuesday
and we had a monday and we had this and
i kind of like the monday night double
header that we haven't had in a few
weeks now the nfl with the virus raging
all around the various facilities where
the teams are located they have found a
way to strike a balance
to manage anyone who happens to be
positive and it happens all the time
half the league last week was dealing
with it chris but also to get the games
in and as we get to the point where
teams have nine games played we are at
and exceeding the total games that were
played in 1982 in the strike shortened
season it was nine regular season games
nobody applies an asterisk to that
season so
look i don't know maybe an asterisk gets
applied to this entire year for a
variety of reasons but at the end of the
day they're going to crown a champion
and they've gotten in enough games by
now that they can pull it off yeah no
it's been great it really has i mean
let's just uh hope you didn't jinx it
right there and we continue to see
football every week but yeah things are
doing going in the you know i want to
say in the right direction but they've
done a really good job of managing the
situation about as well as you can
without a bubble and that's been pretty
impressive
yeah i jinxed it by mentioning it i have
now somehow cosmically redirected the
course of the virus over the next
several weeks and the nfl is going to
shut down and not even have a super bowl
at any point between now and february
and it's all my fault all right sunday
surprise draft i give you the first pick
all right well i mean i think i gotta go
the biggest surprise is probably the
crap stew i saw down there on the pirate
ship yesterday last night all right all
right matey we're dialing up some crap
stew on the office fed is that they fed
you guys for lunch yeah crap that's
right it was a good old crap stew there
but yeah i mean especially the
buccaneers offense that's what i'm
talking about i mean that
how how could that not be the shocker of
the weekend
you know to
okay yeah you'll lose to the saints but
lose to the saints how about get
dominated by the saints with the three
interceptions no run game i mean can't
get outside of your own
20-yard line for the most part of the
football game you know get a turnover in
the second half here there's a short
field tom brady everybody go down they
can't even get points there i mean that
was the shocker of all shockers the week
they bring antonio brown back and we
just go i mean i'm on the show last
night old i mean they're going to be
tough to match up against across the
board i mean geez
that was just
disappointing on all levels execution
physicality one team came to fight the
other one like it was like they already
anointed themselves as the coolest thing
in the nfl and uh that was pretty
surprising to me
when you paused there and you said that
was just
but i was wondering what was going to
come out of your mouth
last night
last night when you said bull crap on
the set and you made my tarico nervous
oh my god you made me nervous 700 miles
away i was like oh no there's the
christopher i know every weekday morning
uh yeah but that that was and you could
pick a bunch of different things but hey
tom brady at a time when it felt like
they were getting their sea legs and
they were making their move and they
were going to be the most complete team
in the nfc and the force to be reckoned
with they got smackdown hard yeah and i
don't know how long it takes to recover
from that one and it really is going to
make some
some people nervous and there's going to
be maybe some subtle finger pointing and
you know is is
does tom still have it he goes from one
week looking like he has it the next
week he doesn't is it bruce arians is it
the defense is it this is it that guys
are going to be looking who is the one
that that was most responsible for this
mess i think the truth is everybody's
equally responsible for the crap stew
that was served up on the pirate ship
last night all right let's stay in the
state of florida even though the game
wasn't played there but down in miami
they got reason to be very excited about
tua last week he got an incomplete he
didn't need to do anything last week
because the defense overtook the rams
before tua ever had to heat up going
head-to-head toe-to-toe with kyler
murray tua had to step up and he did
and look
i never bought into the idea that he's
auditioning for the job the question is
i mean he's got the job the question is
is he the long-term answer every team
wants a 15-year franchise quarterback
you need to find out this year
whether there's enough there to make you
think that tua can be the guy because
you may be in position
in april of 2021 to draft to trevor
lawrence or adjusted fields depending
upon what happens with the texans or you
could package the texans pick which
likely will be in the top 10 if not the
type 5 with your own pick and move all
the way up if you want to try to do that
you need to know what tua is before you
can make that decision so you're
evaluating tua so far so good i was
stunned at how good he was yesterday and
now we've got three quarterbacks taken
in the top six that so far have proven
to us this year that they've got it
which is only going to mean chris
more quarterbacks taken high in the
draft going forward because teams are
going to be more convinced that's where
we find the answer right to our question
of who the hell is our quarterback and
it's only going to make them more
expendable as they go too because
like we're talking about we're already
talking about a guy who hadn't played a
game it was six was the fifth pick of
the draft and we're going
well maybe they're just auditioning him
and see what he's got because they want
to draft somebody at number one next
year i i think it's the way the current
nfl is going to continue to go i do
because i think teams are going to start
to realize man look at all the teams
that continue to have success with
quarterbacks on rookie contracts i mean
they're it's it's a lot i mean it really
is there's there's something to be said
about it there and the quarterbacks are
coming in ready to play you know tua was
impressive yesterday he was you know hey
i'm not going to sit here and anoint him
king quite yet but i i do like the look
of it and that was a big step from week
one to week two definitely so you know
good for him brian flores everything
they got going they're uh they're
kicking butt all right i think my next
sunday surprise is
i mean i know they won the game
but i don't care it was still
surprisingly bad and i'm gonna go with
the steelers defense i am i mean i don't
i don't care that they won the game and
caused turnovers they let up 364 yards
to the dallas cowboys offense you know
constantly
third down conversions for the dallas
cowboys constantly in third and short
and third and manageable i mean
pittsburgh just
really was very lackluster throughout
the game and was very fortunate that
they won that game they were outplayed
and really i think if it's
you know
i think really if you have another
quarterback who just has a little bit
more experience i don't want to take
anything away from gal garrett gilbert
there but
man
you know 1915 third down it's pittsburgh
he throws that ball with pressure around
the ball pops in the air minka
fitzpatrick intercepts it that was a
huge part of that football game to where
man i'm not so sure that didn't save the
day but pittsburgh was lackluster all
day on both sides of the ball but i was
more disappointed with their defense you
know that was a game where they should
have steamrolled the cowboys in their
current situation and they they really
in a lot of ways were pushed around
yeah i agree with you completely there
next one from me matthew stafford even
though he was gone for most of the week
from practice do the covet 19 reserve
list this is still one of the great
passers in all of football just a few
years ago you had him at number three on
your quarterback list he has since
dropped but he's going against a viking
secondary that has a bunch of guys who
are young
who aren't nearly as good as they need
to be who were injured who were banged
up and
uh
he just he just
didn't look like the guy that he used to
be
he didn't look like the guy that the
lions need him to be had a couple of
interceptions there were openings there
for the lines to make it interesting
and and look i know he was through a
difficult week and and maybe we
we
uh underrate how important it is to be
around for practice
but uh
man you know right when it seemed like
the lions were starting to turn it
around
they they've now gone the other
direction and lost two in a row
and it just feels like the storm clouds
are back and there's going to be some
huge changes and shireen williams and i
were talking about this on friday's
pftpm
if they move on from matthew stafford
it's going to create a fascinating
question as to where he could land next
year because there's going to be a team
that'll jump on him yeah if the lions
move on yeah but man all he arrived in
2009 as the first overall pick in the
draft and it just feels like they're
constantly spinning their wheels to try
to become competitive and uh yesterday
they they spun their wheels right to a
34 to 20 loss no i know and and you know
i mean
i feel like the shelf life of matt
stafford in detroit it is coming to an
end you know again i get you know they
play hard
they compete they're just not a real
talented football team there's just no
other way to say that and you know and
then the other thing i think that stinks
about it is yeah stafford's had some
moments during the game and or this year
where he just made some bad mistakes and
some bad moments that have really put
them out of football games or at least
put it made it really tough you know hey
i wouldn't be shocked to see him on
another team next year i wouldn't i
think you're going to see movement
across the board at the quarterback uh
on the you know the quarterback position
so i got one more pick here
yes
okay we got a minute left all right so i
think my sunday surprise the last one i
think my last one i'm gonna go to my boy
blue in buffalo bills and josh damn it
yeah now i gotta find another because i
mean the fact that i you know i thought
he might have a good day and do those
type of things but the fact it was just
gonna be like hey screw the run bombs
away all day long i'm not going to make
any turnovers and be awesome against
seattle
i mean really they kind of played and
did to seattle what seattle does to most
people which is score and then we'll
create a turnover or two to give our
quarterback one more possession and
we'll win the game and that's what
buffalo did and i got to give josh allen
a lot of credit and what they did on
that offensive side of the ball
all right you know i've already given
jake lewton some love i was going to
make him my sunday surprise but but let
me let me give a little let me give a
little credit where it's due to daniel
jones it's a surprise you didn't have an
interception yesterday it's a surprise
they got a victory i'm looking at uh
uh
let's see any fumbles oh two fumbles but
none lost
right and he's three and oh against
washington
owns the washington football team maybe
he should be playing well no he
shouldn't be playing for washington he
should always play a team that plays
against washington so at a time when
many people were saying that many are
saying that daniel jones should be
replaced as the giants quarterback
he proved himself at least for one day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports